hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnusson invitational we are continuing
the coverage with the mess hall there is
a Fallujah vs. Fabiana Caruana
and I didn't get to catch the games
online since they were pretty much
focused on them on the Magnus match but
when I finally checked out the game I
was I was a very pleasantly surprised so
I do hope you're gonna be as well if you
haven't seen the game as it's quite a
complicated one so this is Game one
fuchsia with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have d5 c4 c6 so Fabia also goes
for the Slav defense like Maxime knight
of three we have Knight to f6 and now
Queen to c2 sorry about that we have D
captures on c4 by Fabi now preparing to
defend the pawn would be 5 and E for now
just grabbing the center and b5 now so
one of the one of the rare cases where
you can defend the gambit pawn so b3
holidays are now challenges this
structure.c captures with 8 captures and
each six by Fabi so far B grabs a pawn
but if you lose you get some some nice
open diagonals and a semi-open file for
his rook and also excellent mm-hmm
excellent central control so Bishop to
d3 Fallujah continues development Bishop
to b7 and we have castles here Bishop to
e7 and now there is a game where Bishop
DDT was played but he looked at e1 is a
new move so already as of move 10 we
have a completely new game and the Fabi
still has the player moves Knight night
here rook the c8 pushed the c5 pawn and
free up the the white square bishop and
he will be able to enjoy his extra pawn
so h6 first we have Knight to c3 and now
a6 important to further guard the b5
pointed as at some point you do want to
push c5 so h3 by Allah raised and now
Knight B to d7 preparing rook to c8 and
c5 if possible we have Bishop to e3 in
the now rook the c8 and E 5 now by
Alireza
we have Knight to d5 and here Knight
captures on d5 so kind of preventing
black from pushing c5
as black now recaptures with the C pawn
which will which will kind of be a
problem for his light square bishop but
but okay he does get the the open C file
for his rook Queen to be two and here if
you're if you're careless for example if
you castle here then Bishop captures an
h6 just wins for white characters
captures well you cannot capture if you
capture then it's then it's game over if
you don't capture you you just wandered
upon since now there's the maid threat
and well whatever you play captures
captures in the end it all
it all will end in mate and on IG v and
now threatening to capture here followed
by Queen g7 mate if Queen d7 it just
goes all the way to mate King g8 now
Bishop to h7 check you have to go to h8
now Bishop f5 King here check blocks and
now the bishop captures on f7 will be
made so it would be very unfortunate to
Castle here which Fabi doesn't of course
Knights the b8 by Fabi re maneuvering
that night but also opening up again
some ideas along the C file so also
possible was just nice to be six here
and maybe just waiting to see what will
happen but here a very interesting thing
happens after night to be it was played
in fallujah pushes b4 and now and now
the C 4 square is available so now Fabi
could in fact we go back 97 to b6 to c4
but instead a Fabi goes for her Luke the
c4
instead of bringing the Knight to c4 he
brings the rook here and he offers
he's already up a pawn so he's basically
offering the exchange here to create a
passed pawn here I probably capture with
with the D pawn open up his lights for a
bishop and have a nice pass pawn on c4
so fallujah declines it he just adds
another defender to the b4 pawn and now
nice the d sir now the night is coming
to b6 with nights to e1 and now
tonight's the b6 we have Quinta e 2 now
with now with a trick allowing Fabi to
capture on on b4 and there is no there
is no reason to capture on before but
Bobby does it anyway and this gives
future some reading room
the world basically solves all his
problems on the Queen side here Fabi
captured on before future captures we
have captures and now captures here with
check and now if you capture them just
captures with check picks up the bishop
so Fabi instead went and Knight to d7
but again you are able to trade
everything we have night to d3 going
after the bishop here and the Fabi
trades we have eight captures and Knight
captures and now just castles instead of
trying to defend the pawn Bobby decides
that it's time to to castle the safety
so instead we have castles and now
fallujah just grabs the b5 pawn and here
from all of that madness that was going
on and the Queen said we now have equal
material with bishops of opposite colors
so we have Queen to b6 Fabio furs to
trade Queens and well basically offering
a trade of knights also so just Queen
captures future doesn't want to trade
Queens a queen capture some before and
outlook to a one preparing rook to a
seven so Bobby stops that we have Queen
to b6 and now Queen to e7
we have burst of the c6 shifting the
bishop over over to help out with the
defense of the Kings side rook the c1
and now Bishop to b5
we've looked the c7 and now Bishop to d3
so now you do have some pressure here
but it's unclear how you how you will
break through here so King h2 by
Fallujah and now push up to g6 defending
the pawn so now the rook can be
activated Quintus e5 now fuchsia wants
to trade Queens but now it's Fabi that
declines we have Bishop to f4 and now
comes a rook to b8 we're preparing to
start and attack with the rook as well
Bishop to g3 and now rook the b1 and
here a future plays Bishop to h4 and to
understand Bishop to h4 we first have to
check what happens if Luke the CH check
if rook to CH check then you go King to
h7 and then after Queen to f8 of course
following checkmate black will move the
bishop bishop to e4 and now white is
just lost because after a queen to h8
check came to g6 you have some problems
here because of going to a fun followed
by queen g2 checkmate
so after f3 defending you're still gonna
get Queen to f1 which will follow with
Queen Queen here with mate and here you
have to play Bishop to h4 to start
making room for your king but you are
you are lost and anyway
for example Bishop age for Queen g1
check you're gonna go here now comes
Queen to e1 check King here and now you
finally pick up the Bishop after check
queen characters here and now you're
gonna get to check mated so because of
all of that if you lose your first place
brush up to h4 so he doesn't have to
worry about an escape square for his
King and Bobby does the same for example
now if you with Bishop to h5 so his King
also has an escape square on g6 but not
Bishop to e4 which kind of makes sense
as you want to check mate on G - the
problem is that you no longer defend the
f7 Square so now Queen e7 is extremely
strong followed by a captures captures
in the mate so instead of a bishop here
we have instead of Bishop three four we
have Bishop to h5 and now fallujah goes
for rook the c8 check with Quinta h7 and
now it's an incredibly complicated
position you know what white is trying
to do and you know what black is trying
to do but there is only one move that
saves fallujah here in this position so
even feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only good move for
Volusia while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as it's an
incredibly hard move to find and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to f6 and now black can no
longer continue the attack for example
if you try something like Queen to f1
just you know the usual stuff going for
some some Queen - h1 ideas then there's
this very nice rook to h8 check and now
if you if you pick it up then Queen
trips King here and this is checkmate
and if you don't pick up the rope which
of course you shouldn't King to g6 now
because of the bishop here preventing
you to come to g5 now Quinta see to
check is well just the game over after
the Queen blocks Queen captures here
will be checkmate the King has nowhere
to go so after Bishop to f6 black cannot
continue the attack black has to settle
for a draw rook the h1 check now you're
going to capture and Queen to f1 check
King to h2 and now Bishop to f3 is a
draw for black but it's also incredibly
hard for black to find these only moves
that that draw after if you lose just
Bishop to f6 but it's it's really
awesome so I decided to show it so here
you don't really have a good defense
against this you have to capture and now
it's just a perpetual so this is with
the best play from both sides Bishop to
f6 only move for future however future
played Queen the CT with check and here
for B just blocked it of course you
don't win the rook Bishop g6 and now
Queen back the c5 now again he forced
the bishop back here so now the King no
longer has an escape square now he wants
to of course go Queen to f8 but now
fabi's faster Queen to f1 and fusion now
finds it Bishop to f6 but now it is it
is too slow simply because here Fabi
just plays Bishop to e4 he again gives
his King the g6 square and it was in
this position on 139 that ali reza
future resign the game and the game one
goes to Fabi so here you resigned
because the the same trick no longer
works check of course you don't capture
and allow this checkmate you're just
going to go to g6 and here you don't
have any any good move so if ff3
blocking checkmate then just wrote me
too and you cannot stop checkmate on g2
so incredible game really really really
complicated I really enjoyed it hope you
did as well now I would like to thank ml
Brandenburg Jeff Kloster Ron Swanson
Alexander's - Danny - Gilbert and
Jonathan star for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I'm thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day